¿Se enfrenta Rusia a la mayor tormenta económica
de los últimos 20 años?
¿Esperaba el presidente ruso, Vladimir Putin
un castigo económico, político y militar
tan grande?
¿Podrá la economía rusa resistir esta especie
de Tsunami?
¿Hasta dónde están dispuestos a llegar
los aliados?
Atentos.
Moscú ha llevado a cabo la mayor ofensiva
militar en Europa desde 1945.
Una ofensiva que nos ha dejado imágenes que
creímos nunca jamás volveríamos a ver en
la vieja Europa.
Nos equivocamos.
Los tanques, la artillería pesada, los combates
aéreos o el bombardeo de ciudades están
de vuelta.
Claro que, en esta ocasión, lejos de recibir
los vítores, los elogios y la aclamación
popular por las victorias en el campo de batalla,
Putin se ha encontrado con una enorme tsunami
de pérdidas, condenas y castigos a lo largo
y ancho de todo el mundo.
C1 (“La invasión rusa de Ucrania marca
un punto de inflexión.
Amenaza todo el orden de posguerra.
En esta situación, tenemos el deber de ayudar
en lo posible a Ucrania a defenderse del ejército
invasor de Vladimir Putin”.
Olaf Scholz, Canciller de Alemania)
Los aliados se lo advirtieron una y otra y otra vez:
La cruel e injustificada invasión de Ucrania tendría consecuencias devastadoras para la sociedad, la economía
y, también, para el propio ejército ruso. Queridos amigos, amigas, en este vídeo os
vamos a contar exactamente como Estados Unidos,
la Unión Europea y, en general, todos aliados
de la OTAN buscan dañar, erosionar y hasta
destruir la economía así como buena parte
del poder de Rusia.
Y ojo porque quieren conseguirlo a pesar de
que este país seguirá siendo un importantísimo
exportador de petróleo, gas natural y materias
primas.
Así que la pregunta es, ¿Cómo demonios
hacerlo?
¿De qué forma se le puede parar los pies
a Vladimir Putin?
¿Cómo están castigando los aliados a Rusia
por la invasión de Ucrania?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
Pero, un momento, porque muchos nos habéis
preguntado si existe alguna forma de colaborar
con Ucrania en esta guerra.
Y lo cierto es que sí: además de mostrar
vuestra condena a la invasión, el Banco Central
de Ucrania está aceptando donaciones de todo
el mundo para apoyar a las fuerzas armadas
y la resistencia ucranianas.
Esto no es publicidad, evidentemente nadie
nos paga por decir esto.
Lo hacemos a título meramente informativo
porque pensamos que os puede resultar útil.
Si os interesa os dejamos el enlace en la
descripción.
T1 (EXPULSANDO A RUSIA DE LA ECONOMÍA MUNDIAL)
La guerra se libra en muchos frentes de batalla
distintos.
Y uno de ellos es precisamente el de la guerra
económica.
Estados Unidos, el Reino Unido y la Unión
Europeo fueron muy claros: Si Putin invadía
Ucrania Rusia se enfrentaría a un castigo
sin precedentes.
¿Y sabéis qué?
¡Dicho y hecho!
Esto es exactamente lo que están haciendo.
Ojo, no solo para intentar parar la guerra
sino también y, quizás, sobre todo para
limitar el poder, la amenaza y la influencia
de Rusia.
Si la invasión de Ucrania ha dejado algo
claro es que al final un país con pocos recursos
tiene muchas limitaciones:
insuficientes suministros, equipos viejos,
mala instrucción, y un largo etcétera de
problemas de todo tipo.
Por mucha propaganda que haya, la realidad
se termina imponiendo:
M(Rusia es un país relativamente pobre y
muy corrupto.
Así que su ejército por muy grande que sea
tiene más agujeros que un queso gruyer.
Es algo que todos hemos podido ver, a la hora
de la verdad las fuerzas armadas rusas padecen
carencias de todo tipo.
Lo que, por supuesto, tiene consecuencias.
Por ejemplo, todo apunta a que durante apenas
los 5 o 6 primeros días de la invasión los
rusos sufrieron en Ucrania más bajas que
Estados Unidos en Afganistán durante 20 años.)
Pues bien, tal y como ya os contamos, el objetivo
es castigar a Putin y limitar la capacidad
económica de Rusia mientras este país siga
siendo hostil.
Claro que puede que muchos digáis, [sí,
sí, Enrique estas son las típicas cosas
que se dicen, que suenan muy geoestrategicamente
inteligente pero que luego suelen terminar
en prácticamente en nada.
Pues, podéis creerme si os digo que esta
vez los aliados van muy pero que muy en serio.
La invasión de Ucrania lo ha cambiado todo.
Y su primer objetivo ha sido arrancar de cuajo
a Rusia del sistema financiero internacional
Para ello las potencias occidentales ha puesto
sobre la mesa
3 vías de actuación:
(En primer lugar, las sanciones han buscado
reducir la financiación extranjera para el
gobierno, los bancos y las empresas rusas.
Para hacerlo, los aliados han aprobado limitaciones
a la compra de deuda y sanciones contra los
principales bancos del país.
Por ejemplo, Estados Unidos, ha bloqueado
entre varios otros a los dos principales bancos
del país, el Sberbank y el VTB, que juntos
controlan casi el 60% del sistema financiero
ruso y que ya no pueden operar con bancos
norteamericanos.
No pueden hacer operaciones en dólares.
Y claro, la mayor parte de las operaciones
internacionales se realizan, precisamente
en dólares.
Y además no se trata sólo de Estados Unidos.
Reino Unido y la Unión Europea han hecho
lo propio.
[Vamos, que les ha dejado tiritando.]
La segunda vía de actuación ha sido quizás
la más esperada de todas: la expulsión de
muchos bancos rusos del conocido como sistema
SWIFT.
El sistema de mensajería internacional que
conecta a la mayoría de bancos del mundo.
(El SWIFT, una cooperativa con sede en Bélgica,
ese un sistema de comunicación interbancario
que participa en más de la mitad de todos
los pagos transfronterizos de alto valor.
Cada día tramita más de 40 millones de mensajes
financieros entre más de 11.000 instituciones
financieras de todo el mundo.)
Pues bien, ahora una buena parte de los bancos
rusos quedarán excluidos de este sistema.
Cuando en 2012, se expulsó a los bancos iraníes
del SWIFT estos sufrieron una catástrofe,
de repente ya no podían gestionar las transferencias
internacionales porque no podían comunicarlas.
En el caso de Rusia no todos los bancos estarán
afectados, o al menos no de forma completa.
Los europeos quieren seguir comprando el petróleo
y el gas ruso y para ello tienen que poder
pagarlos.
Además, luego están las deudas que los rusos
tienen contraídas con los bancos occidentales
y que, por supuesto, estos quieren recuperar:
unos 121 mil millones de dólares.
Sea como sea, el daño al sistema financiero
ruso será más que considerable, porque sí,
existen alternativas a SWIFT, pero son más
caras, entrañan problemas de control y a
muchos bancos nunca les va a compensar utilizarlas.
Así que, de una forma u otra los bancos rusos
excluidos dejarán de tener acceso a una parte
importante del sistema financiero mundial,
lo que podéis haceros una idea: complicará
y encarecerá el comercio, la inversión extranjera
o, sin ir más lejos, la gestión de las remesas.
[Una enorme patada.]
La expulsión del SWIFT ha sido la sanción
más mediática de todos, sin embargo, el
auténtico golpe ha sido la decisión de Estados
Unidos, la Unión Europea, el Reino Unido
y Canadá - A los que puede que se sume algún
otro país - de bloquear al Banco Central
de Rusia y con ello la mayor parte de sus
reservas internacionales.
Y es que veréis, tal y como os contamos en
un pasado vídeo una de las grandes bazas
con las que contaba Vladimir Putin eran los
más de 600 mil millones de dólares en reservas
que Rusia ha acumulado durante los últimos
años en forma de dólares, euros, oro, yuanes,
etcétera, etcétera.
Fijaos.
Pues bien, ahora gran parte de estas reservas
ya no están.
Al menos el gobierno ruso ya no puede echar
mano de ellas.
C3 (“Esta es una especie de bomba nuclear
financiera que está cayendo sobre Rusia...
La guerra llegó y el dinero se esfumó - el
dinero se perdió antes de que la guerra terminara”.
Sergei Aleksashenko, exviceministro de finanzas
y ex vicegobernador del banco central de Rusia)
Las reservas, amigos, hacen falta para pagar
las importaciones y también para apoyar la
moneda local.
Por ejemplo ante la huida de capitales y la
salida de inversiones que están provocando
la guerra y las sanciones, el Banco Central
de Rusia ya no tiene los recursos necesarios
como para apoyar el rublo, lo que hará que
éste se desplome asestando un duro golpe
a todo el país:
La inflación se disparará, los ingresos
reales se desplomarán, el valor ahorro se
volatilizará, etcétera, etcétera.
Los argentinos conocen muy bien este proceso.
Simple y llanamente de golpe y porrazo el
bloqueo del banco central le ha arrebatado
el equivalente a cientos de miles millones
de dólares al gobierno ruso.
Hablamos de una medida que hasta ahora sólo
se había tomado contra Irán, Venezuela y
Corea del Norte.
[Rusia, en mundo club te has metido]
Todo esto ha obligado al gobierno ruso ha
tomar medidas muy severas:
(Al poco de anunciarse las principales sanciones
el banco central ruso, para intentar frenar
la huida de capitales, tuvo que subir los
tipos de interés al 20% desde el 9,5% anterior.
Esto por supuesto tiene un efecto muy negativo
sobre las empresas y las familias rusas.
El gobierno también ha tenido que imponer
un férreo control de capitales que, por ejemplo,
impide que los rusos puedan enviar dinero
al extranjero libremente o que los inversores
internacionales liquiden sus inversiones en
la bolsa rusa.)
Y, ojo, porque no solo hablamos de Estados
Unidos, el Reino Unido o la Unión Europea:
muchos otros países como Japón, Corea del
Sur, Australia, Canadá, Noruega o Singapur
también están imponiendo sanciones a Rusia.
¡Qué demonios, hasta la neutral Suiza se
ha sumado a patear al gobierno de Putin!
(Suiza respalda las sanciones completas de
la UE contra Rusia.)("El fondo petrolero de
1,3 billones de dólares de Noruega abandonará
sus inversiones rusas.
FT)Pero aquí, aquí amigos, no termina todo.
Una vez que los aliados están expulsando
a Rusia del Sistema Financiero Internacional
también quieren aislarla, atentos.
T2 (RUSIA, MÁS SOLA QUE NUNCA)
Junto a las sanciones financieras, los aliados
también están aprobando sanciones comerciales
que por ejemplo le impiden a Rusia comprar
productos críticos, como por ejemplo, componentes
tecnológicamente avanzados.
Al mismo, el riesgo de violar alguna sanción
y el riesgo reputacional está haciendo que
muchas empresas hayan anunciado que van a
cancelar todas o buena parte de sus operaciones
en Rusia.
Este es por ejemplo, el caso Volvo, Daimler,
Disney, Jaguar, BP, Shell o Equinor, Intel,
UPS, Fedex, AMD, entre otras muchas.
Y por supuesto el país también está siendo
suspendido de todo tipo de organismos y competiciones
culturales y deportivas: desde Eurovisión
hasta el Mundial de Fútbol.
(La FIFA y la Uefa suspenden a todos los clubes
y a la selección nacional.
BBC)
Pero si hay un campo en el que se comienza
a ver que supone realmente el aislamiento
de Rusia, ese no es otro que la aviación.
Tanto la Unión Europea, como el Reino Unido
y Canadá han cerrado su espacio aéreo para
los aviones rusos.
C4 ("Nuestro espacio aéreo estará cerrado
a todos los aviones rusos, y eso también
incluye los aviones privados de los oligarcas".
Ursula von der Leyen, presidenta de la Comisión
Europea.)
Y no solo eso.
Los aliados también han establecido fuertes
restricciones a la venta de todos los bienes
y tecnología vinculados a las aeronaves.
Es decir que si un avión va a Rusia y tiene
un problema, la aerolínea se arriesga a quedarse
tirada por no poder conseguir las piezas que
necesita.
Por eso muchas compañías internacionales
están suspendiendo sus vuelos a Rusia .
Y aún más, la Unión Europea también ha
prohibido que las compañías de leasing de
aviones trabajen con aerolíneas rusas.
Y, ojo, porque más de la mitad de las aeronaves
comerciales en Rusia son arrendadas, que por
otra parte es una operativa muy normal en
la industria.
[Vamos que entre unas cosas y otra los cielos
de Rusia se van a quedar la mar de vacíos]
APodemos decir que Rusia está siendo expulsada
de la comunidad internacional.
Y, desde luego, sin dinero, sin comunicaciones
y con restricciones de todo tipo…
Ya me diréis qué futuro tiene su economía.
[Que quereis que os diga, pinta mal, muy mal,
para para Putin y para Rusia.]
Luego además de todas las sanciones financieras
y comerciales, Estados Unidos, la Unión Europea
y el Reino Unido han puesto en la diana también
a los oligarcas rusos próximos al Kremlin
y a los pesos pesados del gobierno.
A muchos de ellos les van a investigar, les
van a congelar activos y prohibir la entrada.
¿Y sabéis qué?
Hasta Mónaco se ha sumado a esta línea de
trabajo.
C5 ("Estamos apuntando a los aviones privados
de los oligarcas, atacaremos sus propiedades
y apuntaremos a otras posesiones que tienen".
Liz Truss, Secretaría de Relaciones Exteriores
de Gran Bretaña)
Así que no resulta extraño que estén siendo
precisamente los oligarcas los primeros que
empiezan a cuestionar la invasión en el entorno
de Putin.
N4 (Los principales oligarcas rusos están
hablando en contra de la guerra en Ucrania.
Vice News)
[Ay, ay, con lo bien que vivían]
Esta, queridos amigos, es la otra guerra,
la guerra que están librando los aliados
contra Rusia.
Pero hablamos de una guerra…
El castigo también alcanza el campo militar.
Sí, sí, lo habéis oído bien.
Atentos.
T3 (ARMAS, ARMAS Y ARMAS.
UN ARSENAL ENORME)
Vladimir Putin se las veía muy feliz: el
ejército ucraniano no podría hacer nada
contra la formidable movilización rusa.
Sin embargo, como todos sabéis, la historia
ha sido muy diferente.
Las tropas rusas se han encontrado con un
ejército mucho más robusto y mejor equipado
de lo que pensaba.
Y no solo eso, tras la invasión, los suministros
de los países OTAN y aliados comenzaron a
llegar como si no hubiera mañana.
Si al principio países como Alemania eran
reacios a suministrar armas a Ucrania e, incluso,
vetaban las entregas que otros países como
Estonia querían hacer de armamento fabricado
en Alemania, luego todo cambió.
De repente las presiones de Estados Unidos,
Reino Unido, Polonia o los bálticos surtieron
efecto: todos se han dado cuenta que cada
día que los ucranianos resisten las cosas
se ponen peor, mucho peor para Rusia.
(La inmensa mayor parte de los gobiernos europeos
están anunciando grandes entregas de armas
al ejército de Ucrania: armas antitanque,
sistemas de defensa aérea, munición, suministros
alimenticios, chalecos, rifles, etcetera,
etcetera.
Incluso la propia Unión Europea ha anunciado
que va a utilizar su Fondo para la Paz para
financiar la compra de armamento para Ucrania.
Armamento entre el que se incluyen cazas Mig-29
operados por algunos estados miembros y que
los pilotos ucranianos saben pilotar.
Es la primera vez en toda la historia que
la Unión Europea destina fondos a la adquisición
de armas.)
Todo esto ha hecho que el ejército ucraniano
pueda resistir mejor y cause grandes daños
al ejército ruso.
Un ejército al que cada día de combate le
cuesta una fortuna que no tiene y muchas bajas.
¡Hasta Suecia se ha sumado a esta enorme
campaña!
El país escandinavo se ha comprometido a
enviar más de 5.000 misiles antitanque y
miles de chalecos y cascos entre otros equipos.
De hecho, prácticamente las únicas excepciones
han sido Hungría, que se ha comprometido
a donar miles de litros de combustible pero
no armas y España, que ha enviado un cargamento
con algunos chalecos, algunos cascos y muchos
guantes, batas y mascarillas, muchas mascarillas.
Cosas de la política española.
El caso queridos amigos es que así es como
Estados Unidos, la Unión Europea, el Reino
Unido y todos los aliados quieren castigar
a Rusia por desatar el horror de la guerra
en Ucrania.
Y de paso limitar
Pero llegados hasta aquí, turno para ti:
¿Qué te parece la estrategia que están
siguiendo los aliados?
¿Qué crees que tendrían que hacer?
¿Funcionará no funcionará?
Déjanos por aquí abajo tus comentarios.
Y ahora si este vídeo te ha resultado interesante
no olvides darle a like y suscribirte a VisualPolitik.
En próximos vídeos os hablaremos de otras
muchas consecuencias que esta guerra va a
tener para Rusia y para toda Europa.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí,
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.